N
MYANMAR AND WHAT CAN BE DONE TO
EASE TENSIONS THERE.
HONG KONG MEDIA TYCOON JIMMY
LAI AND 8 OTHER OPPOSITION
ACTIVISTS HAVE BEEN CONVICTED
OF ON AUTHORIZED ASSEMBLY IN
THE 2019 PROTESTS.
WILL BE SENTENCED ON APRIL
16TH.
THE CHARGES CARRY A MAXIMUM
PENALTY OF 5 YEARS IN PRISON.
OUR WILL RIPLEY IS IN HONG KONG
WITH DETAILS.
HE JOINS US NOW.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, WELL.
WHAT MORE ARE YOU LEARNING
ABOUT THE CONVICTIONS, THE
POSSIBLE SENTENCES, AND HOW
MUCH OF THIS IS ABOUT MAKING AN
EXAMPLE OF THESE ACTIVISTS?
>> THIS IS 100% ROSEMARY ABOUT
MAKING AN EXAMPLE OF THESE
ACTIVISTS.
EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE NOT
CHARGED IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE
UNDER THE NATIONAL SECURITY LAW,
JIM ELI, EVEN THOUGH GRANTED
BAIL IN THIS CASE, WILL STAY
BEHIND BARS AS HE HAS FOR
MONTHS NOW BECAUSE ON CHARGES,
PEOPLE ARE NOT AUTOMATICALLY
ALLOWED TO LEAVE.
SO, FOR PARTICIPATING IN A
MARCH AT VICTORIA PARK, I'M
VERY WAS PACKED INSIDE THE PARK
THAT DAY, NO CELL SERVICE, IT
WAS MCGEE, RAINING, AND
EVERYONE WALKED OUT OF THE PARK
AND THEY MARCHED THROUGH THE
CITY.
THEY HAD THIS MOMENTUM FEELING
THEY WILL ACCOMPLISH SOMETHING.
AND TODAY, IT'S ENDING RIGHT
HERE, JUST A COUPLE DOZEN
REPORTERS, NO PROTESTERS, AND A
CITY CHANGED FOREVER.
>> A FATHER FIGURE FOR A
SO-CALLED LEADERLESS MOVEMENT.
JIMMY LAI, MEGA WEALTHY MEDIA
MOGUL REVERED BY HONG KONG'S
YOUTHFUL PRO-DEMOCRACY
PROTESTERS, TARGETED BY
BEIJING'S DRACONIAN NATIONAL
SECURITY LAW, DEVISED TO
SILENCE THEM.
DO YOU FEEL THAT SOME ASPECTS
OF THE PRO-DEMOCRACY MOVEMENT
HAVE PUSHED CHINA TOO FAR AND
LOST?
>> IT'S ALWAYS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO, IT'S TO FIGHT FOR YOUR
FREEDOM BECAUSE WITHOUT FREEDOM
WE HAVE NOTHING.
>> LAST YEAR, THE PUBLISHER OF
THE APPLE DAILY WAS FROG
MARCHED OUT OF HIS OWN
NEWSROOM.
THE CANTONESE PRO-DEMOCRACY
PUBLICATION TURNED OVER BY 200
HONG KONG POLICE.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE BEING
INTIMIDATED. I THINK THE LAW'S
INTIMIDATING IS VERY EFFECTIVE.
>> THE CATCHALL NATIONAL
SECURITY LAW BANS SEDITION, AS
WELL AS COLLUSION WITH FOREIGN
POWERS.
A CHARGE OFTEN LEVELED AGAINST
LAI. VIOLATORS CAN FACE LIFE IN
PRISON.
AS THE IMPOSITION OF THE LAW
LED TO MASS ARRESTS, THE
GUIDING OF HONG KONG'S
LEGISLATURE --
>> WHAT'S THE POINT IN TAKING
PART IN ANY MORE LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL ELECTIONS?
>> THE MAVERICK MEDIA MOGUL
PUBLICLY APPEALED TO THE U.S.
YOUR SUPPORT.
BEFORE THAT, HIS TIES TO THE
U.S. WON HIM A WASHINGTON MEET
AND GREET WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
>> THEY SEE THE LOGIC, THEY SEE
THE RIGHTEOUSNESS IN IT.
IT'S LIKE WE HAD SUCH A GREAT
SUPPORT FOR THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY.
>> LAI HAS ALWAYS ACTED WITH A
SENSE OF RIGHTEOUSNESS. ONCE A
REFUGEE FROM COMMUNIST CHINA,
HE'S LIKELY RAP SHEET A BADGE
OF HONOR.
JIMMY LAI IS STILL PLAYING THE
LONG GAME. YOU WANT TO MOVEMENT
TO CONTINUE WITHOUT COST THE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT YOU?
WE DON'T HAVE A YOU HAVE?
>> WE HAVE TO BELIEVE THEM, WE
ARE ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF
HISTORY.
GIVEN ENOUGH TIME, WE WILL WIN.
TIME IS OUR WEAPON, NOT
VIOLENCE.
>> TIME, MANY HERE WORRY IS
RUNNING OUT.
>> LAI AND 6 OTHERS FOUND
GUILTY AS THEY AWAIT THEIR
SENTENCING.
SOME HAVE BEEN GRANTED BAIL.
OTHER NOTABLE DEFENDANTS HERE,
HONG KONG'S DEMOCRACY FATHER,
SOME OF THEM WILL BE WALKING
THROUGH THE STORES IN FRONT OF
THE CAMERAS BUT NOT JIMMY LAI.
AT 72 YEARS OLD, HE WAS DENIED
BAIL IN THIS NATIONAL SECURITY
LAW CASE AND HE STILL HAS AN
ADDITION TO THAT TRIAL TO MORE
TRIALS INSIDE THIS COURTROOM
FOR OTHER UNAUTHORIZED
ASSEMBLIES HE'S ACCUSED OF
LEADING.
HAYS 72 YEARS OLD.
CARRIES A MAXIMUM OF 5 YEARS IN
PRISON.
WHEN I SPOKE TO HIM LAST YEAR
AFTER'S ARREST, ASKED ABOUT THE
REAL POSSIBILITY THAT THESE
CHARGES COULD KEEP HIM IN
PRISON AWAY FROM HIS MEDIA
EMPIRE, AWAY FROM HIS HOME AND
HE'S AT PEACE WITH THAT.
BECAUSE HE BELIEVED IN WHAT HE
WAS FIGHTING FOR IN HONG KONG
EVEN IF IT APPEARS AT THIS
STAGE THEY LOST THE WAR.
>> IT IS A VERY TROUBLING
SITUATION THAT HAS COM